hello everybody it is seven o'clock you
are very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show here on sky news this
tuesday morning prime minister pictured
with a glass
in his hand at least seven bottles on
the table
including champagne gin and in a nod to
the pandemic what appears to be hannah
hand sanitizer this was eight days after
england was put back into a strict
lockdown because of rising covey cases
but when boris johnson was asked if
there'd been a party in downing street
he told mps no and whatever happened he
was sure the rules were followed at all
times some senior conservatives have
concluded this wasn't true and are again
calling on him to quit in a few moments
we'll be asking the transport secretary
grant chaps what he thinks
it's tuesday the 24th of may senior
conservatives turn on boris johnson over
photos that appear to show him partying
in downing street
they're very difficult
to watch frankly it's very difficult to
look at those photographs
because they don't give the impression
of seriousness that i think we really
need
in our country
also ahead mps conclude that the uk's
withdrawal from afghanistan was a
disaster and accused the foreign office
of lacking leadership and accountability
i'm in odessa as britain discusses plans
with allies to send a naval task force
to the black sea to try and lift
russia's blockade of odessa and other
ukrainian ports and try and get their
grain out to the hundreds of millions of
people who vitally need it
plus scientists warn the uk is in a race
to identify new cases of monkey pox
before it becomes entrenched
an extraordinary act of kindness by a
wigan plumber helping to keep pensioners
warm this winter after they spoke to us
on sky news i understand these companies
are going to make money i understand
they've got to maintain that their
equipment that they've got but not at
the rate of a life not the rate of
someone dying because they can't afford
the standard charges never mind the gas
that they need
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world in full bloom a new
ride for her majesty as the queen visits
the chelsea flower show
and she went to a war zone and returned
with a new friend
we'll speak to a journalist who rescued
this dog while reporting from ukraine
and they're joining us in the studio
later on
[Music]
which i am very excited about good
morning the prime minister is facing new
calls for his resignation after pictures
of him were leaked that appeared to show
him partying in downing street uh
transport secretary grant chaps is with
us uh on the program this morning good
morning to you morning thanks for
joining us have you been offered a cup
of tea i have not but uh but uh thank
you very much four bottles of wine two
bottles of fizz bottle of gin eight
blurred out people
how do we explain that yeah i mean look
i've talked about this before because as
i've told you my uh dad was in hospital
during this period we thought we'd lost
him in fact we didn't see him for the
best part of four months i've talked
about my you know anger about
uh about that in the past um however i
think these are things that we've known
about the prime minister has said it
shouldn't have happened and he has
apologized and of course the police have
spent their time investigating it as
well so i don't think the fact of the
pictures us seeing them for the first
time changes what the police and sue
grey would have already known yeah but
the prime minister did say that he
thought that everybody was following the
rules
yes and and look i i i don't want to say
otherwise because i'm disappointed to to
to to see what happened in downing
street and we know now because the
police have issued um fines
that um that that wasn't right and you
know but the prime minister has
completely reformed downing street set
up a new office of the prime minister
has a new permanent secretary
running that so it's completely
reorganized um has apologized which i
think is is very important and of course
it's been thoroughly investigated how
disappointed are you with the prime
minister
well i don't think these things should
have happened but i think it's probably
worth
recalling in context that throughout
this period the prime minister himself
had been seriously ill had a close brush
with coronavirus he lost his mum during
the period he's dealing with the
pandemic
by the looks of things he goes and
thanks somebody who's leaving um raises
a glass to them and you know as i say i
i
having
like everyone in this country lived
through coronavirus and in many cases
made
enormous sacrifices um don't enjoy um
seeing pictures that suggest anything
else but this is well-covered territory
we've seen this we've known about this
and the only difference is seeing the
photograph sure i mean the problem is
transport secretary that he misled
parliament didn't he no i don't look
like the question is was he down there
partying no clearly not he'd gone by to
to say thanks and raise a glass to a
colleague who was leaving um and uh you
know
the answer to this of course is that the
police have spent a lot of time with a
lot of people and a lot of resources
crawling over it uh and they've come to
their conclusion as we know he wasn't
fined for that then i understand that
but there's a difference between the
police investigation and what he said in
parliament and if you'll indulge me i
just want to remind our viewers what
happened on the 8th of december
and the question at prime minister's
questions
from the labour mp katherine west who
specifically asked about this event
will the prime minister tell the house
whether there was a party in downing
street on the 13th of november
prime minister
mr speaker no but i'm sure that and
whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times
comfortable with that yeah well look at
as i say the he he goes where he's true
he goes he he goes down i mean
i see his boxers are in the which which
is his work work boxes see it looks to
me like he goes down on his way uh out
of the office and thanks the the staff
and raises the glass and doesn't in
his mind recognize that as a party and
indeed the police
have looked into this um spent a lot of
time and resources to say and i don't
i'm not i'm not but let me just pick you
up there if i made transport because
people who were at that event have been
fined
well and and we know from other events
including the the the the birthday um
yeah you know event that um some people
in the room were and some people weren't
and the police will have the reason but
i'm not there to double sort of you know
double guess the either the met police
or in fact the durham police who are
looking at different incidents and they
have to look at the evidence
along with sue gray and come to their
conclusions and i know in the case of
the police they have super great i'm not
asking about the police i'm asking about
what he said in parliament when he said
there was no event on the 13th of
november what did he think was happening
where are all these bottles on the table
well look i i think probably what
happened is he's at the end of a busy
day he walks down he says cheers to
somebody who's worked there and walks
out and to him that is not a party but
actually of course we know that there's
a final stage to this which is mps
themselves through the privileges
committee will be looking into what he
said to parliament as well um so we'll
we'll we'll even have i mean this thing
has been pretty well investigated i
would say and uh there will be further
investigation so you won't be short of
further investigation i get that but
there were more than two people in one
room and there was booze on the table
and um he was there and he said later on
in parliament that nothing happened what
did he think people would do well he
would have been in and out of rooms and
with with lots of people
who are working on coronavirus lots of
the time someone's leaving he goes and
thanks them and raises a glass now look
i don't as i said to you i have personal
reasons for
feeling
quite strongly emotional about that
period
of time in the sacrifices that
people were making myself included so
you know i don't seek to defend it nor
does the prime minister in fact has
apologized uh you know i think that the
police sue grey and the privileges
committee at the right places for these
things to be looked into the police have
already done their job as i said i don't
attempt to second-guess their work
whether that's the met police or indeed
the the durham police with the the
leader of the opposition that is the
police's job to look at those things and
make their determinations we have
confirmation this morning that
uh the meeting that took place between
sue gray and the prime minister
yesterday the minister told us that it
was the instigation of sugray then
number 10 told us otherwise we're being
told this morning it's been confirmed
that um
during that meeting the prime minister
asked su grey to drop the report
look i wasn't at the meeting but i know
there were official
officials there the meeting was actually
arranged by officials just on the timing
and logistics of the of the report so uh
beyond that i'm afraid i don't have any
use how would you feel about the
suggestion that the prime minister had
asked for this report to be dropped
given that publicly he said that
he was looking forward to it well look i
haven't seen that but what do you think
it's really important to know
my viewers this morning will think what
do you mean he asked for the report to
be dropped well as i say i i i wasn't in
the room so i don't know that's the the
what i do know in the case what i do
know is uh it's perfectly normal and
proper in fact it happened before sue
gray's interim report for there to be a
brief conversation where they just talk
about timing and logistics of the report
exactly what was discussed i don't know
but you know fortunately and i think
this is one of the great things about
this this country we live in a country
where you know
everybody has to stick by the rules when
they don't for example the fixed penalty
notice that we've seen uh is issued we
have uh proper processes in in place and
sue gray uh i know from the interim
report let alone what she may well say
next has identified a number of
shortcomings in number 10 from that
period of time the prime minister's
already picked up on a whole series of
them and made very fundamental reforms
in downing street including a a brand
new office of the prime minister which
we've never had in this country before
to make sure that propriety and ethics
are followed at every turn you talk
about proprietary and ethics
the person that is carrying out what
we're told was an independent report is
called into the office of the prime
minister and said drop the report no
look again i i wasn't
there i don't know that's the case
that that happened well again i haven't
heard that but what i do know is how do
you feel about that but hold on a minute
first of all still the facts what i do
know is it was officials in number 10
who arranged for the two of them to have
a brief discussion
but it was a but it was a technical
discussion about timing uh of the report
and total and a totally normal thing to
happen before a report like this is is
published and quite what they discussed
you seem to have had more information
about the inside of the meeting than
than i do
i wasn't there
i'm very impressed the only thing i have
to say is that you know sometimes
occasionally things get reported which
are not entirely uh accurate the civil
service were there uh
to make sure that all the correct
processes were followed so i have no
particular reason for concern about the
two of them meeting that's normal it
happened before the interim report and
unless we're you know
casting aspersions on sue grey which i
don't think anyone needs no we're not no
i don't think anyone is i i well we'll
have to wait to hear from sue but i can
i i can assure you sue gray will be
completely uh open and uh she has a
fearsome reputation so i'm sure uh we'll
find out
strong women they really get under your
skin don't they um as far as the police
are concerned should they be looking i
mean are you completely comfortable
that that there were no more fines to
the prime minister given that somebody
who was actually at the same event that
the prime minister was out saying um
that they felt that it was completely
unfair i can't work out why he's not
been fined and
are shambled
well look i'm not here to criticize the
the met they have a job to do they threw
in loads of resources to this a lot of
people have spent a fortune i don't
think you were asking me about it last
time i was on have spent a a fortunately
and have turned over all of the evidence
uh that that they had uh enormous access
to so i'm not here to sort of second
guess did the police get this right or
wrong as i say you know the police have
a difficult job to do in all these
circumstances whether it's the prime
minister uh you know um during the the
you know holding a glass up to say
cheers to somebody who's who's leaving
uh and whether he was therefore just
dropping by to move on uh or you know
still against the law at the time well i
was gonna say in the case of the um of
the
birthday uh wishes uh event some people
seem to have received fines and some
didn't i don't know why and similarly
we've got this police investigation of
the leader of the opposition and the
deputy leader of the opposition up in
durham and i don't seek to second-guess
what they're doing either i think we
have to let the police in this country
who are entirely independent get on with
their job okay so just before we move on
because i want to ask you about ukraine
you're completely comfortable about that
photographs on the front page of the
paper well look i'm not i've already
told you i couldn't see my own dad for a
long period of time because we were
obeying the rules um but i also accept
that the prime minister has long since
apologized has made fundamental reforms
in number 10 and i've no doubt if he had
his time again uh would not have
would not have dropped by to say thank
you to a member of staff leaving so no
i'm not but it is
it is what it is uh and we're about to
talk about ukraine and there are you
know the potential for industrial action
on our railways many other things that
the country does need to get let's move
on to ukraine and what are we doing to
try to get this grain out of odessa i'm
very concerned about it i met with my
opposite number alexander kubrickov last
week who's the infrastructure transport
secretary of state in ukraine i met with
him in germany last week and we were
discussing uh details which i i can't go
into but about how infrastructure could
be in place to ensure that grain leaves
i'm specifically concerned with the
situation in ukraine we've seen this
barbaric invasion by putin what really
worries me is we've seen many lives lost
in ukraine
we could see even more lives lost in
other places in the world through grain
and food shortages which could be even
greater than the lives lost in the war
directly so we do need to find solutions
to getting this uh are we going to try
and organize safe passage well we're
looking at all the different options and
as i don't want to go into detail with
my conversation with uh kubrickov but uh
there are lots of different potential
ways to get grain and other goods out of
the country and the goods into the
country as well i think it's absolutely
essential
that we do otherwise there could be a
lot of
hunger indeed even famine
which could dwarf the numbers involved
in the war itself some of the papers
this morning suggesting that we may send
um military ships down there in order to
try to organize that safe passage you
you will have seen the speculation i
can't go into specific detail there are
a lot of complexities to this including
mined waters
in the near odessa port uh
clearly uh the situation with russia and
putin and their
their approach to this could make that
very difficult but but as i say the big
top line is
it's hard to um overestimate the extent
to which ukraine was and is the bread
basket of the world actually their flag
which is the the blue on top of the sky
and the yellow underneath is actually
the the grain or the corn or the wheat
is that it's the fields um and and it's
because they are such a big producer of
of of the world's food so it is
important that we uh seek to help them
find ways to get it out closer to home
if we have a rail strike are we going to
prioritize freight trains so that there
is still food on the shelves yes we'll
do exactly that but look i i don't i
love the railways and i know the people
who work on them do as well i don't want
to see
um strikes on our railways i think this
is very very premature uh i noticed that
the unions were saying it's because they
want their pay on frozen it is going to
be on frozen no one's talking about pay
staying where it was we do have to
balance
rail workers with the needs of doctors
and nurses and teachers and the rest of
the public service
and so it is important that we get that
balance right
the taxpayer has put in 16 billion
pounds that's 600 pounds per family
household whether you use the trains or
not and we've done that to keep the
trains running no one lost their jobs
during coronavirus but we do need to
reform our railways so i'm looking to to
to get this resolved i want the unions
to do that as well i urge them not to
call strikes i think it will be
completely counterproductive to a
railway which frankly is on life support
and that could give it a heart attack
but just to confirm that that you will
prioritize freight trains if necessary
correct yeah okay so that the we don't
need to worry about uh empty shells no
we'll make sure that we get because
freight and distribution and the supply
chain are absolutely critical and
talking about
food from ukraine you know making sure
that distribution both of energy and
food nationally takes place is very
important and we'll of course will
prioritize that but i think it's
important to recognize you know our
railways can't carry on we've lost a
quarter of our passengers add a quarter
of the income and actually they haven't
been reformed for many many
years i want to build up a bigger
railway uh ultimately but i need to work
in cooperation with the
unions on that and and i really hope
that they'll do that rather than as i
say essentially just as the railways are
trying to recover uh give it a heart
attack we are out of time but i throw
enough brick bats at you a bouquet um in
the form of a road haulier who i spoke
to in wigan last week and he said it's
got much better for royal haulage now
and there aren't the challenges that
they had before so next time grant chaps
is on your program can you tell him so
there you go thank you we took 33
measures to try to help that market and
get fresh it's working again and i'm
pleased to hear that it's good to talk
to you thanks so much thank you mr
thanks uh looking at the front pages i
wonder what they're thinking downing
street this morning partygate dominating
this morning's front pages the metro
leads with the publication of photos
apparently showing the prime minister
giving a toast at an event that broke
lockdown rules that was in november of
2020. the guardian has a similar picture
showing boris johnson holding a drink
inside number 10. daily telegraph
reports that the met police is coming
under pressure for not finding boris
johnson for attending the leaving event
for his aid the daily express has the
headline nothing to see here also in
response to the prime minister not
getting fined
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll speak to the london
mercede calm as the new elizabeth line
finally opens to the public after more
than 10 years and almost 20 billion
pounds spent on the project
going to speak to richard ratcliffe the
husband of nazanin zagari ratcliff she
was forced to sign a false confession
before leaving iran
i'm joined by a former afghan mp who
escaped the taliban as a report outlines
deep failures of leadership in
government during the evacuation from
kabul
cross party foreign affairs committee
has concluded that the uk's withdrawal
from afghanistan and chaotic evacuation
of kabul was a foreign policy disaster
that helped embolden
vladimir putin to invade ukraine and the
transport secretary warned on this
programme a moment ago that more people
could die around the world because of
the russian blockade on grain and food
exports than in the war itself our
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn is in odessa for us um hi
dominic good morning to you i'm sure you
heard what the transport secretary said
they're looking at options as far as
odessa is concerned
yeah and i think it's interesting to
ponder as to whether liz trust who today
is reported to be considering along with
lithuania and other allies the idea of
sending a naval task force to the black
sea to lift that blockade whether that
is a serious consideration or whether
it's just something that she has been
dreaming up to keep readers in the daily
express happy and
interested but a solution will need to
be found because this is a huge crisis
that is brewing here okay one in 20
people around the world got their food
from grain grown in ukraine uh last year
because it was a bumper harvest and
because it has really rich soil that
allows it to export 70 percent of its
crops normally that would be getting out
through the ports behind me but they are
standing still none of it is getting out
here a trickle across the land borders
into the european union we traveled
through the grain belt of ukraine to
talk to farmers to see what this is
doing to them and then we came here and
gained rare access to the ports here to
discuss with ministers and officials
here exactly what this will mean and the
disastrous implications it could have
for the rest of the world
for mile after mile stretching across
ukraine a rippling green sea of wheat
this is why they call it the bread
basket of the world
when dutch farmer keys hussinger first
came here to farm 20 years ago
this is what drew him here
i mean this is
this is perfect and it's the famous
ukrainian black soil i mean it's the
best soil in the world
seventy percent of what ukraine's
farmers harvest is exported last year
feeding 400 million people around the
world but barely any of it is getting
out now with the country blockaded by
russia
making farmers like keys increasingly
desperate and there's still 25 million
tons of grain
and oil seeds left in ukraine that's the
third of last year's harvest the only
option is to get
the grain out of ukraine is through the
black porch they have to be open that's
the only option there's currently enough
grain stuck in ukraine's silos to feed
all the world's least developed nations
for a year the world was already facing
a food supply crisis because of covert
19 climate change and rising fuel prices
but if ukraine can't get its grain out
of these silos and to the international
markets that crisis could become a
catastrophe for hundreds of millions of
people
ukraine's black sea coast it's port
stand idle
we gained rare access to the port in
odessa which should be busy exporting
last year's harvest
nothing is happening here now
this is ukraine's problem and the rest
of the world's over here a quarter of a
million tons of ukrainian grain in these
vast silos and across the dock here a
vessel that's got 60 000 tons of grain
in it that hasn't moved since february
because until russia's naval blockade
out at sea is lifted
none of this is going anywhere vladimir
putin has his heel on the jugular of the
world's food supply if safe passage
can't be found through these waters the
chaos and suffering he's brought to
ukraine will also be felt far away from
here
well i think it's one of the rules of
war k that the effects of a conflict are
not confined to the area where it's
being fought and that certainly will be
the case here if this grain can't get
out to those hundreds of millions of
people who need it if you look at what
happened in the arab spring climate
change led to rising uh wheat prices and
that undoubtedly helped fuel the unrest
that caused such chaos and turmoil
across the arab world we could see that
happening elsewhere in the world in the
middle east and elsewhere that that ship
and that report has 60 000 tons of grain
bound for egypt a poor country that
desperately needs it and that's a
fraction of what needs to be got out of
these ports the solutions are fairly
limited you can get a little bit more of
it out of the land crossings into europe
but issues like red tape and differences
in railway gauge make that very
challenging the ukrainian minister we
spoke to the deputy agricultural
minister we spoke to here says that he
would like to see the ukrainians given
more weapons by the west to attack
russia's navy itself the alternative to
that is the west sending its own navies
in as liz trust is reported to have been
discussing with allies to escort these
ships out now that is fraught with peril
because it could see western navies a
lot in confrontation with their russian
counterparts potentially leading to a
kind of world war three situation that
is a thorny dilemma for western
policymakers to grapple with but the
impression you get is that three months
into this conflict to the day they've
only really begun thinking about it and
trying to come up with solutions okay
dominic for now thank you
in other news the us president joe biden
has said there had been no change of
policy on taiwan despite his comments
yesterday when he volunteered military
support for the self-governed island
claimed by china he made the remarks
during a visit to japan tom standing by
for us um the question again i suppose
is good morning tom whether he misspoke
because his uh comments were clarified
very quickly weren't they by the white
house
morning k yes they were very shortly
afterwards and clarified again by the
president himself today what's at stake
here is this idea of strategic ambiguity
which has been the us policy towards
taiwan and china for a long time
basically not saying whether or not they
would support taiwan militarily in terms
of troops on the ground in the event of
a chinese attack on taiwan and that's
again what he reiterated today he was
asked directly if he would send troops
to taiwan if china invaded and he says
the policy has not changed at all i
think all of this has to be seen of
course in the con context of ukraine
first of all this tour of asia uh
president biden's first tour a sign that
the us is focused on asia despite uh its
interests in ukraine and second this
idea of strategic ambiguity even if the
policy hasn't changed perhaps the
feeling is that putin obviously wasn't
deterred in his invasion of ukraine and
they don't want to make the same mistake
with china so even if they're saying the
policy hasn't changed perhaps showing uh
behind it hinting that there would be a
firm resolve if china were to attack
china regards this as its own internal
affair it sees taiwan as a breakaway
promise it didn't seem too rattled or
they did put a firm response saying it
would safeguard its territorial
interests
okay for now thank you
so in four minutes time actually it's
already open the elizabeth line has just
opened we'll be speaking to the mayor of
london sadiq khan in just a moment or
two nazanin zagari ratcliffe meantime
says iran forced her to sign a
last-minute false confession at the
airport in tehran as a condition of her
release she also says the uk government
official was with her when she signed it
under duress before iranian authorities
would let her leave mrs zagari ratcliffe
was released in march six years after
being arrested on spying charges i knew
that that was like a last minute game
because i knew they were they told me
that they have
been given the money so what is the
point of
making me sign a piece of paper which is
incorrect it's a forced confession to
all the things they have been accusing
you exactly and also the british
government
not um questioning it
why i have to do it so a british
official was with you she was with me
yeah
but also the whole thing was filmed the
whole thing of me
signing the first confession was filmed
and we are going to hear from her
husband uh very shortly indeed here on
the programme not before the weather
though
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
an active jet stream will bring gusty
winds and spells of rain over the next
few days but there will be some brighter
spells too and things should settle down
for the weekend
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
let's have a look at some cool picks for
you should we put together by marlon for
you this morning telegraph lovely photo
of the duchess of sussex giving her
husband a big kiss
after he won a polo tournament in santa
barbara on sunday looking at the
guardian for you
lovely picture here as wow how cool is
that um it's a group of puffins on the
farn islands near northumberland uh the
birds return every year around march or
april to breed after the after spending
the winter out at sea
and finally
why did the duckling cross the road well
because they were following their mum of
course all 24 of them they were spotted
walking across a residential road in the
norfolk village of ashel and so all the
cars just waited until they managed to
cross the road well done you mom for
having 24 the queen uh meantime um i
went to the flower show yesterday and i
saw her majesty she was look she's got
new wheels and she was looking very
sprightly indeed she arrived in a buggy
to tour the gardens the queen is patron
of the event run by the royal
horticultural society and has attended
more than 50 times in her 70-year reign
buckingham palace said it was a
last-minute decision for the 96-year-old
monarch to attend and she's been
suffering from mobility issues
the queen is about to celebrate her
platinum jubilee
something that no other monarch has done
that 70 years of duty dedication and
service
sky news will bring you the celebrations
and pageantry to mark this historic
occasion plus
a very special guest
i'll be joining the sky news team as we
celebrate the very best of britain and
we cannot wait that's the platinum
jubilee on sky news
coming up we're going to be speaking as
i said to richard ratcliffe the husband
of nazanzigari ratcliffe who's revealed
she was forced to sign a false
confession before leaving iran in march
that to come
[Music]
hello again everybody uh you're very
welcome to join us here on the breakfast
show on sky news this morning top
stories for you some senior
conservatives have turned on boris
johnson over photos that appear to show
him partying in downing street and the
transport secretary warns on this
program a moment ago that more people
could die around the world because of
the russian blockade on grain and food
exports than in the war in ukraine
itself
also scientists want the uk is in a race
to identify new cases of monkey pox
before it becomes entrenched
as i said grant shaps was on the show
just a few moments ago and i asked him
whether the prime minister misled
parliament after pictures emerged of him
raising a glass at an event at downing
street during lockdown when he'd
previously denied that a party took
place
the question is was he down there
partying no clearly not he'd gone by to
to say thanks and raise a glass to a
colleague who was leaving um and you
know
the answer to this of course is that the
police have spent a lot of time with a
lot of people and a lot of resources
crawling over it it looks to me like he
goes down on his way uh out of the
office and thanks the the staff from
raises the glass and doesn't in
his mind recognize that as a
party mayor of london sadiq khan is with
us to talk about the elizabeth line but
just let me put that to you mr khan good
morning to you um before we talk about
the success of the elizabeth line um are
you completely comfortable with the
investigation that the metropolitan
police has done given the pictures that
are all over the front pages today
well it's very important i explained to
you your views i've been assiduous as
the police and crime commissioner who is
the later politician
not to get involved at all
in an investigation from the met police
into a political opponent it's right and
proper that there's operational
independence but i think the reality is
when we police by consent when we need
the confidence of the public when it
comes to policing issues when questions
are being asked about police
investigation and its integrity that the
police explain
some of the conclusions they've uh
reached i think it's right and probably
they do so
uh yes of course there are big questions
about whether the prime minister misled
the house
there clearly was a party he was raised
in his glass to empty wine bottles uh
there sue grey will be published in a
report later on this week but i think
the police should be explaining how they
reach their conclusions that's the right
thing for them to do
how surprised are you that he wasn't
fined for that event
well i i want to get into
what's happened all i've seen is a photo
yesterday for the first time and as a
normal citizen forget as a police and
crime commissioner i did beg a number of
questions that's why i think it's
important because many people across the
country will be having similar questions
that they met police explain how they
reach their conclusions they may have
seen other evidence it's for them to
explain so and the reason why it's
important is because we're pleased by
consent we need to have confidence in
our police
the police must police and investigate
without fear or favor but i know from
reading the newspapers today from
watching sky news this morning from
speaking to londoners there are many
questions uh they have including to
boris johnson to explain how you can be
raised in a glass have an
booze lying around and it'd not be a
party and at the same time weeks later
tell the house of commons uh there
wasn't a party
yeah we'll move on to crossrail in one
second just a final point on that though
if i may i mean rule breaking law
breaking in your city
should the met come to explain to you as
the mayor of london
why there haven't been more fines in
downing street
well that's so more than a hundred and
twenty uh fixed penalty notices fires
have been issued
by the police into downing street
parties no other address as i understand
in the country
has had so much law breaking over the
recent uh past i am asking the met
police to provide the urgent clarity i
think they've got to provide not simply
because you're asking the question but
people across the country not
unreasonably will be saying hold on a
second
i followed all the rules i was
meticulous in relation to following the
rules those that broke the rules were
fired and here we have a photograph
which looks like uh the prime minister
uh courts red-handed at breaking uh the
rules some would call it a smoking gun
so the police should explain
how it is that more fines weren't issued
that being said it's really important i
make this point uh again and again i've
not been involved in investigation
there's been independence it's improper
for me as a political opponent uh to be
telling or advising and instructing the
police what to do but i think there are
legitimate questions people are asking
which is why i'm asking the police to
write the clarity
okay um talk to me about the elizabeth
line it's been a long time coming
well listen the first plans for this
particular line were talked about in the
1940s before sky news
first went on air the first bill aborted
attempt uh at 1991
i remember ken livingston the first man
lobbying for this and i gave credit to
tony blair gordon brown for giving the
green light the first bill
went through parliament uh when i first
became an mp 2005 royal ascent 2008 when
i was a transport minister in 2009 the
first construction began in canary wharf
and last week her majesty the queen
formally opened this line named after
her in this platinum jubilee it's a
remarkable transformative railway line
it's a landmark moment for our city
it'll contribute 42 billion pounds
towards our nation's economy the trains
are built in derby uh the doors for the
stations in cheshire the signage in the
isle of wight the steal from dorset more
than 70 000 jobs already created around
the country i'm proud as the mayor but
also as a brit
but there's a bit of an issue 73 miles
long which is a it goes from essex i
believe to berkshire but some problems
uh with construction at bond street is
that right so you can't actually travel
the whole line in one go until next year
so this this new line today is more than
100 kilometers from reading in berkshire
to shenfield in essex at the moment you
got to just jump off the train and get
on another train at paddington uh
and then at liverpool street and that
was always a plan but the good news is
rather than waiting a year as was the
original plan uh before that to be fully
integrated it will happen this autumn as
it is in london often you've got to
change from one line to the other so the
dlr you you clock in clock out the same
goes for the waterloo and city line
nothing new there except what is new is
these uh trains are air-conditioned you
can walk through the stations are like
cathedrals i'm here at farrington where
you've got a sideways lifter going down
so look let's enjoy these hundred
kilometers
from the west in reading to the eastern
essex and be proud of this fantastic
engineering feat
sounds amazing looking forward to
traveling on it mr mayor thanks very
much indeed for joining us
you'll love it
thank you looking forward to it um
sadiq khan saying he wants the police to
explain themselves yes urgent clarity he
says is needed about their
decision-making something the met have
not done and don't generally do because
he says people will see this photograph
and think the prime minister has been
caught red-handed he said breaking the
rules that everyone else was following
and i think the pressure is only going
to escalate on the metropolitan police
to explain why it appears that other
people were fined over
gatherings on that date the 13th of
november but the prime minister picture
their glass in hand in front of various
other people even if as grant shaps put
it he just wandered in for a minute gave
a speech and left did he not think this
appears to be a party and i should do
something to stop it because he said it
wasn't a party and uh he said he has the
comments indeed he said asked whether it
was he could clarify whether there was a
party he said no so it also raises
questions about whether he's misled
parliament so big questions for the
prime minister and the police already
and we've only seen one photo we haven't
seen the full su grey report which we
believe will be arriving tomorrow and
just another thought for you kay i think
a lot of people are focusing on whether
as a result of this tory mps will force
a leadership challenge against boris
johnson and our general thinking is that
they probably won't but that is not the
only measure of whether this has been
damaging of course um it has arguably
been quite a damaging few months the
tories didn't do very well in the local
elections and they're struggling to
find answers to the cost of living and
other questions and boris john if boris
johnson's authority is chipped away at
as a result of all this that could make
things very difficult just a thought on
the
story from our deputy political editor
sam coates saying that this meeting that
that did take place between um sugree
and the prime minister the prime
minister was putting pressure on her
that's right this is quite an incendiary
claim
from sources to sky news that as a
result of this meeting at the beginning
of may between boris johnson and sue
gray initially claimed that she
initiated but downing street admitted
yesterday that number 10 officials had
initiated it it is now claimed and sky
news understands that
it was suggested that sue grey might
want to drop the whole report because we
according to the account in the times
anyway boris johnson said oh well we now
we know it all it's all out there that
you may not want to do the full report
now we don't know what she said and of
course we're expecting the report to
come out tomorrow and no one is doubting
her probity but certainly the idea that
the prime minister would have suggested
it will outrage a lot of people sure i'm
sure um we'll see you at the top of the
hour thanks very much indeed tomorrow
thanks we've been telling you about
nazanin zagari ratcliffe she said that
she was forced to sign a false
confession under duress as a condition
of her release from iran she spent six
years in prison after being arrested on
spying charges that she had always
contested
uh nazinen's husband richard a friend of
the program is with us now as you can
see hi richard it's great to see you
haven't chatted to you since um she was
uh released and brought back to the uk
how are things at home i bet the baby's
thrilled isn't she
yeah no that's right it's a much nicer
context to be having these kind of
interviews now um
and as you say yeah it's it's a whole
new world for us um a lot more relaxed
um gabriella i'm very pleased to have
another back you know kind of
i don't think i appreciated quite how
angry she used to get
um now means back much calm i mean
there's a bit more
navigating between the you know the
commands of two parents and rather than
just having to maneuver her dab around
her little finger um but yeah
i think it's you know for all
of
the tensions of that first interview for
all of the tensions of the fourth
confession with about now it's it's it's
a whole different world uh to be back
home
now talk to me um about what happened
before she left iran and why she wants
to talk about that now
yeah so um just before leslie was left
uh was allowed to leave the country she
was taken on two occasions
um on the monday before she was taken
um to a revolutionary guard office in
the middle of the night but late nights
at 9 00 pm until 11 p.m um and was
required to sign a forced confession
that she resisted um she'd been taken
there by british officials
um
wouldn't sign the confession that was
put in front of it it was a blank
template effectively where they would
fill in whatever they wanted to accuse
her of um wrote on something else um
said listen i'm this one i was convinced
to acknowledge that i was convicted of
this
um
two days later at the airport again
another uh version of compassion was
brought in front of her um and this time
the british officials also said listen
if you want to get on that plane you
have to sign this um so very angry i was
you know um as you remember sitting at
home getting texts from her i think i'm
furious of that
um
pleased that she's a
hugely she's home but yeah i think
it it was
startling um that the british government
also required her to sign that
confession
how concerned is she
by
making this public that there might be
challenges for her family back in iran
yeah i think she she was certainly
worried um i think
she
was worried anyway that it was going to
be used um in tv propaganda both in
terms of news pieces but also in terms
of drama series in other ways um that
was what she complained about both to
the foreign secretary um and the prime
minister will be met privately um and
yeah i think generally the criticism
she's made of iranian authorities
um
there's a worry as to what rebounds um
candidly i think it felt very important
that she did it there's a lot of people
friends she's got left behind sitting in
prison cells who are being abused in
other ways and she has a platform where
it's important to say that the area of
authority is a completely out of light
but yeah there's always a risk as to
what happens next
i'm thrilled that she's back and that
family life is getting back to normal
for you thank you very much indeed for
joining us richard great to see you
thank you
lovely to see with a smile on his face
isn't it now to an extraordinary act of
kindness for you may remember last week
during our special coverage of the cost
of living crisis from wigan that a
retired couple whose boiler had broken
remember them while they feared that
they might not survive another winter
until community plumbing charity deffer
cic came to their rescue here's katarina
i'm sorry to celebrate
you know mid-summer last week in wigan
we met godfrey and jeanette ward
they told us how their boiler was broken
unable to afford a new one and pay
rising bills they'd been living in the
freezing cold showering at a neighbors
their story moved people to action
well we've got
this
so when did this get put in a saturday
this brand new boiler was donated for
free after the couple appeared on sky
news what's it been like waking up with
you know hot water again oh great
beautiful
what was the first thing that you did
was wash up
like so many struggling families
jeanette and godfrey are proud they
didn't want to ask for help and when
jeanette got pneumonia over winter and
things got desperate they didn't know
where to ask
well we had to do something up like you
said we couldn't
we couldn't manage another winter i
don't think we would have managed
another winter
and now what do you think now
well
a lot more optimistic now
the wards case might seem extreme
but the plumbing charity that fitted
their boiler says it's helped thousands
of families just like theirs and warns
that as energy prices go up things will
get worse people are going to die and
they are it's not i'm not going to
sugarcoat it i'm not going to say so our
people may suffer our people may go
without people will die i understand
these companies have got to make money i
understand they've got to maintain that
their equipment that they've got but not
at the rate of a life not the rate of
someone dying because they can't afford
the standard charges never mind the gas
that they need
you'd be good okay for now their warm
head and a hand with bills has lifted
some worry but there are many more
living in fear of the future not sure
how and when help will come
caterina totsi sky news in wigan
a group of mps say that afghan allies
and british soldiers were utterly let
down by the chaotic evacuation from
kabul last summer tom tugenhard who's
the chair of the foreign affairs select
committee uh produced the report
i know how much effort
we put in i know
i know what it cost quite literally
so many of us not to be able to get
straight answers out of those who were
charged with leading the evacuation
frankly it's not good enough
well here to give us her reaction to
that report is former afghan mp
shikuriya barakazi it's good to see you
thank you just explain the mask for us
thank you good morning this mosque is
sign of solidarity with the afghan
women's and particularly the journalists
where taliban was ordered that the masks
putting in wearing masks for all tv
anchors and females is compulsory
so that's just the sign of solidarsi how
hard and how difficult is
why you're
thinking it's a lifetime lockdown where
the afghan women's are right now and the
people of afghanistan
talk to me about the report that you
have seen um
the afghan report by rmps here in this
country what what do you think
i think it's really timely report
also the ssd
and the measure the evacuation process
i can understand it was very difficult
but so it was also very chaotic
situation
everything was just out of control
from my understanding but there was a
possibility to manage better and
particularly for those whom they left
behind and those whom they work with the
uk government and particularly with the
british army and there lies in civil
society and other governmental body
organizations the report says there was
a lack of leadership at the top
do you agree with that absolutely right
i myself i always been struggling how i
will be able and who is the responsible
person to be in contact while i was
being stuck in in afghanistan and it was
it was really nightmare because the
phone number they provide there was an
automatic phone
and there was a no one and even a single
email address that could respond back
how to do and what to do where to go and
who's the contact person who do you
think is responsible for that
well it's hard to say because it's not
only one institution
but in such an emergency situation
a little bit of
organizing people and
selecting responsible people
and avoiding
extra unnecessary
bureaucracy is necessary tell us about
your journey from out of afghanistan to
finding yourself in the uk
well my one is very unique one the way i
was being evacuated from afghanistan the
way i has been treated and
with the taliban and yet and i think
still there are some people that home
office don't want to reach to them or
they don't want to listen for instance i
myself
i was not been settled in a hotel and
still i'm in a very temporary place
yet the home office didn't provide me
any housing and i can understand the
exaggeration of those families that for
the almost near nine months they are
living in the hotels with their kids i
think it's very costly
and also it's very devastating to pass
all your time in a tiny room of hotel
and particularly with the kids younger
kids it's very difficult it's like one
trauma we've not been
find ourselves back to passing another
trauma and finding ourselves in a
different environment different culture
coping everything is not easy but we are
trying to be a part of uk
and to not be burnt on their shoulder we
would like to stand on our feet and
contribute back do you envisage your
time when you will be able to return to
afghanistan oh definitely certainly
certainly
i'm i'm here just because i don't want
to live and i don't want to work under
the taliban
regime
from my understanding although they are
eliminating women systematically for me
as a single mother that i have
responsibility for my four kids i should
i should do and serve them so i'm not
able to work there according to
deliberate rules but beside of that my
aim my goal is to be back and i like the
uk government to stand with the people
of afghanistan not with the taliban and
do not give recognition to the taliban
because this is the time that we should
think about our share values from where
we start and where we are right now do
you feel that the british government is
standing with the taliban
well uh somehow they want to be engaged
but we would like their engagement more
with the democratic
alternative address from the taliban
because if as much as you go and give
legitimacy to taliban under name of
engagement or humanitarian aid that much
you give more legitimacy and power to
the taliban and i think enough is enough
talmud are not the group they are just a
terrorist they've been terrorists and
the way the power was been handed over
there was a great mistakes and i think
it's better to learn from the mystic do
not repeat it again good to talk to you
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us on the program this morning
thank you very much indeed thank you
um have you seen those pictures on the
front pages of the papers um today um we
are told by the government minister this
morning that it wasn't a party the prime
minister popped in uh to raise a glass
to one of his aides that was leaving but
it definitely wasn't a party under no
circumstances was it a party it
definitely definitely definitely wasn't
a party
[Music]